do you know these eclipses terms Saros
or soul connects the stars are cool
that's about all I know to the untrained
ear
they sound like Pokemon we hit the
streets of DC and the annual anime
convention Otacon to see if people can
tell the difference I'm going to say
this is the Pokemon FLE honor a flying
because it has lion in it easily it
might be a Pokemon Dave ah that it was
not I'm gonna say the heliolisk is
astronomy turn no appeal eons oh the
point where the earth is farthest from
the Sun solar eclipses would occur
around this period lasts longer due to
less apparent motion you've betrayed me
once Pokemon and probably will again
what generations that from neat-looking
Oh 15 maybe even so that's the rare
pokemon from X&Y
this is the G when three celestial
objects line up in a row
alright I know what acidity is so a
little cheat in there it also is the
Pokemon
I heard it in song well this was easy
they should have been question 1 okay so
Gyarados of course would be problem on
this experience
okay so Saros is an eclipse cycle
laughing it about 18 years at the start
of each cycle an eclipse occurs that is
nearly identical to the one that
happened at the start of the last ice
age so it might be in a different
location I've never heard of it
diagnosed so I'm going to say that say
it's wrong again right oh boy I can I
can see someone yelling zygarde I choose
you hopeful guy guy that sounds like a
TAS or something I was like no three
sorrow cycles okay so that'd be a lot of
years two eclipses an exam on a part
will occur over roughly the same place
okay
I've heard both of those words before
and I don't know it's a glitch another
easy one the Pokemon is Umbreon fact I
just saw I'm brie on a little while ago
and tumblr is the Astronomy term hey
there we go
hey I'm Brianna Pokemon love my Eevee
Estonian Sombra is a shadow cast by the
moon over an area that is experiencing
annual civil Christmas which is kind of
cool cause like I'm Brianna Ness beyond
being like requite up so you're like
saying most night cycles when you evolve
them you choices fine right I suppose
come on alright we got five four five
I think I did better than I was
expecting but not very well either way
this is boosting my pokemon knowledge
with science knowledge and my vocabulary
is a good three four I got five four
five and I think that's because a lot of
the people don't work and also a lot of
my friends really like Pokemon and won't
stop talking about it